Everyone loves midnight snacks.
But you need to sTOP BECAUSE IT’S MAKING
YOU FAT.
Hey guys, Catie here for DNews.
Are you concerned about your waistline?
Of course you are.
Everyone is.
There is no escape.
Well a new study done by researchers at the
Salk Institute shows that consuming your food
within a limited time frame could not only
help reverse the effects of obesity but the
effects of diabetes as well.
At least in mice.
Satchidananda Panda, the professor who lead
the study, conducted a similar study in 2012
wherein he fed 100 mice identical high-fat,
high calorie diets.
One group was allowed to consume the food
whenever they wanted, while the other group
could eat as much as they wanted, but only
within an 8 hour time frame.
One of the groups fattened up.
I’ll bet you can guess which one.
But in this new study things got a little
more complicated.
The study was done on nearly 400 mice of different
sizes, ranging from normal to obese.
He fed the mice different kinds of diets consisting
of high fat, fat and sucrose or just fructose.
And the final difference was there were varying
time restrictions instead of just the one
8 hour window.
To a certain degree, any of the varying diets
and time restrictions showed benefits.
No matter the diet, the mice who had time
restrictions of 9-12 hours showed similarly
lean mice.
The group that was given a 15 hour window,
however, saw less results.
There was also a group of mice that were given
cheat days, and were allowed free range eating
only the weekends.
These mice looked very similar to the mice
who had time restrictions seven days a week,
which suggests that the diet can even withstand
temporary interruptions.
But most significantly, the mice who became
obese due to the free-range diet were eventually
restricted to 9 hour windows.
Although they were consuming the same caloric
amount, within a few days their body weight
dropped by five percent and eating this way
prevented the mice from further weight gain.
While all of this is really interesting, it
isn’t exactly new information.
Intermittent fasting has been a method of
weight loss in humans for several years.
Humans naturally fast-- at least for some
amount of time every night when we go to sleep.
When we wake up, our fast is broken at breakfast.
I know, words mean things sometimes.
A super long time ago humans didn’t know
how to control fire.
So they hunted and ate in the day, and protected
themselves against predators and slept at
night.
Then we learned how to control fire, and THEN
created artificial light, creating an artificial
day, and artificial feeding times.
Our bodies have circadian rhythms that tell
us to stop eating after a certain point in
the day which, unfortunately, many of us ignore.
The later you stay up to say, watch tv with
a bowl of ice cream or drive to taco bell
for that fourth, fifth and sixth meal, the
more your digestive system, along with all
the hormones and enzymes that manage it, are
thrown off and unable to process the food
you eat.
And those extra calories end up in all the
places you don’t want them in the form of
fat.
So restricting your intake of food to a certain
timeframe is basically just extending the
time between your last meal and the breaking
of your fast, which gives your body the time
to burn away your fat stores for energy.
Panda’s research suggests that the longer
we eat the lazier our metabolisms become.
But once you restrict your consumption to
an 8 to 12 hour window, our metabolisms will
burn more calories day and night.
What do you guys think of this?
Are you going to try to stop eating after
a certain hour?
Let me know in the comments below.
Don’t forget to subscribe for all of the
DNews goodness, and you can follow me on twitter
@catiewayne if you want to know what I’m
up to.
See you next time.